[Music]
you guys can probably tell this by
looking at me but I have been fired a
lot in my life as I'm 34 years old and I
look like a Native American meatloaf
impersonator I saw a guy quit his job
the best way ever once I was working at
a restaurant of Texas where I'm from and
this manager Pat and this waiter richer
gotten a huge argument on the dining
room floor and they were screaming back
and forth until finally the manager Pat
Brad Richard and he just goes all right
Richard get the hell out you're fired
and rich your deal back without missing
a beat I don't need this goddamn job
I sell coke it's just the best way ever
to quit your job forget your reference
I'm in the duck game now some which are
gonna be all right
he wasn't he got shot my dad is dead I'm
not great with transitions it's
interesting when someone you know passes
away you get reminded them in subtle
ways after they're gone you know like
you see a picture for you here at Linda
Ronstadt song you drive by a Little
League field if they said they would be
at where's he going with this but the
way my father has chosen to haunt me is
to have all of his debt collectors call
me and there's a grip of them because
the other day was at the food court at
the mall I liked it there and I was just
sitting there enjoying myself by the way
the phrase enjoying myself pretty gross
it sounds like what a Kennedy would call
masturbating
remember pinkies out Ted
but I wasn't masturbating I was having
yeah you laugh like a bully's friend
I wasn't masturbating I was having a
Cinnabon which is a lot like
masturbating cuz you hate yourself at
the end of either and the clean ups the
same you know when you have a Cinnabon
you're like now I have to do laundry to
sleep in it I sitting there with my
Cinnabon and I get a call I'm a
cellphone pick it up say hello woman on
the other end of the line says hello mr.
Torres this is Karen from H&R wagger and
we're calling to get you to absorb your
father's debt and I said well I'm not
gonna do that so where do you want to go
from here know a little bit she got so
damn mad all she started to say was you
have to pay you have to pay you have to
pay she said it in the same cadence that
Romans wrote ships so I knew she is
serious and I'll be honest I got caught
up in it so I started screaming back I'm
not paying I'm not paying squat in the
middle of a godforsaken food court so
everybody around me thinks I'm terribly
upset over the quality of a Cinnabon
there's a much bigger situation going on
and I'll be honest with you guys that
eatin some mushrooms earlier in the day
so now I'm delusion don't think I'm
Spartacus and command everybody in the
food court to burn it to the ground and
I say something like take Orange Julius
first for he is about your Caesar
now bring me a hero
I stopped him cuz I'm a merciful Lord
move back in with Karen
look you have to pay you have to and I
said I'll tell you what Karen let's make
a deal and she said well what's the deal
and I said I will start paying my
father's financial debts to you when you
start repaying his emotional debts to me
so now every week I get a phone call and
it's like hey great game last night want
to go out for a Cinnabon
you